critiqué pour la lenteur de sa campagne
vaccinale la france passe à la vitesse
supérieure
à l'image de l'ouverture du stade de
france comme vaccinodromes le nombre de
personnes vaccinées a fortement augmenté
cette semaine ce vendredi le nombre de
vaccinations en 24 heures a atteint un
nouveau record avec 510 1267 injection
en visite dans un centre de vaccination
de nogent sur marne ce jeudi le premier
ministre a dévoilé que 10 millions de
français avaient reçu au moins une
injection de vaccin
nous avons maintenant l'objectif des 20
millions qui se présente à nous dans
quelques semaines et je ne doute pas que
grâce à cette mobilisation générale nous
allons la tête
parallèlement à la vaccination la france
se lance dans la mise en flacon des
vaccins de pfizer but renntech emmanuel
macron s'est rendu dans une des quatre
usines de production vendredi le
président français a établi un objectif
de mise en flacon pour le reste de
l'année 2021 ces 250 millions de doses
en france en 2021 que je peux vous dire
c'est que ils ont commencé ils sont en
train de monter en puissance très
fortement a expliqué que fin avril début
mai on sera à pleine cadence et qu'on va
encore monter durant l'été et cadence
avec vraiment une mobilisation 24 heures
sur 24 7 jours sur 7
mais sur ces 250 millions de doses 15%
seront destinés à la france selon le
groupe delpharm 45 % seront répartis
entre les états membres de l'union
européenne les 40% restants étant
destinés à l'exportation
si le sérum de phison bio intake à la
confiance des français
le vaccin de l'anglo suédois astrazeneca
restent englués dans la polémique
la faute à la découverte de rares cas de
thrombose après injection après avoir
annoncé que le vaccin d'astrazeneca
serait réservé aux personnes de plus de
55 ans le gouvernement français a
désormais décidé de recourir au vaccin
de pfizer et de moderna pour les moins
de 55 ans à la suite de remonter deux
cas d'événement thrombo-embolique de
localisation inhabituel la haute
autorité de santé a recommandé de
réserver vague des vrilles à aux
personnes âgées de plus de 55 ans avant
cette restriction un peu plus de cinq
cent mille personnes
moins de 55 ans ont reçu une première
dose du vaccin astrazeneca
l'administration d'une seule dose de
vaccin étant insuffisante pour garantir
une protection durablement efficace
la haute autorité de santé recommande
aujourd'hui de compléter le schéma
vaccinal pour cette population avec un
vaccin à arn messager dans un délai de
douze semaines après la première
injection à cette polémique s'ajoutent
les retards de livraisons de doses mais
également une efficacité moindre face
aux variants sud africain ce vendredi la
haute autorité de santé a préconisé de
ne plus utiliser le sérum anglo-suédois
dans les départements où la part de ce
variant est trop importante
sont concernés la moselle la guyane
mayotte ou encore la réunion